my name is bonaventure dussu i am from
benin republic it's located in west
africa
i am at miller doing a
research on a drug discovery project
with professor yoshua banjo we are
working on leveraging deep learning
models
capacity into generating
molecules and doing it much more way
faster and efficiently than a human
would do
i love montreal i love the
uh
intercultural diversity and everything
and i also love the fact that i can
speak french
[Music]
is great like is
as someone who is in the field is one of
the uh miller is known to be the
greatest center of deep learning
research in the world right so everybody
wants to be here so my experience over
has been great
it taught me so many things i think that
from january 2021 until now i've grew up
so much and i'm still learning and i
definitely feel like i made the right
just coming here
that's the goal right that's the goal
the learning process and everything
that's the end goal and also something
that will be super useful and and
like usable by by by everybody because
between i mean what happened this year
also made it very clear that we still
have a lot of progress to do in our in
health and everything so
we want to use our
let me say skills working with computers
to make sure that we contribute all
together to that process